[Music]
how we feeling hot yeah exactly it's
really warm in here
some are unwell and this is a time great
and let's pick a volunteer you sir
what's your name
then it's fantastic so dennis is going
to be a volunteer today so that is have
you ever been you know to like an
authentic dinner with your boss and you
need to sound smart really quickly do
you know that situation you know you
want to terrorize and kind of need
something to say don't worry then it
will go back today it's all about the
first word things I may see some smoke
things like salt I do you know yeah more
who knows what I even means what makes
you sound smart so you know that sort of
situation
okay so very birds would complain to
have a long time today yeah that's right
right it that we didn't just about big
data big data and wanting to take next
level so we got a humungous data you
know we can take IBM you know the
nothing depart on IBM has nothing on
this with a humungous data okay so but
more seriously you know before we start
up we're going to talk about big data
but what do you guys thing is the first
big data system I was maybe created and
yet it then it's come on you must have I
did them regular file system okay little
bit more back in time I think someone
someone has looked at a slide
to the leverage Alexandria Indian sir
right DNA happy human created indeed so
the Library of Alexandria interesting it
could store about 400,000 papyrus
scrolls I love that word
and across 60,000 square meters so it's
huge it's probably the first real system
where you could kind of structured data
inquiry even though it's really really
slow but some estimates say that it's
about four gigabytes forty gigabyte of
data if you do a kind of notification of
20 pages papyrus scrolls and then you
multiply you get about 40 get our data
not bad not bad
so what we're going to do in this talk
is to first start up and give some
background what details were to the
bargain well we care to ten minutes and
then we're going to get a hands dirty
River something really cool called the
walk
nothing to do with Cambridge pop
automation so it's a open source project
created I'm not people and then we're
going to look at how can scale leave the
expired processing and emphasizing
questions on the ground so who has
watched plastic surgeries raise your
hand
there's no need to get change same
environment hands okay stays in this
room
so Vin Diesel bullets the awesome part
infuse the usable as people X which we
rerun it to people green that's what we
dig data it three characteristics way
that people talk about this before you
will ask in the variety inspector
container so what the Toyota so you know
but it is something quite quite simple
Tunes pigments things I have sold a lot
on computer so if we think about
Facebook till death do you say book you
like together teaches health
divorces all right so I can have a
Facebook you know they even took billion
users now and let's say the daily
average contribution is one megabyte of
data okay you do lost occasionally you
end up having all then 300 survival
information for a single year right so I
saw the biggest anemia or maternal paid
by information that's not even counting
things like replication so volume is a
big issue for infrastructure compute a
good way to think about it is that well
I don't know straight from a machine
somewhere to partner with yes I mean you
said it I've got too much information
ethically share some information with
you know this place like the work but I
went some issues in terms of
coordination and prosthetic to suddenly
what's inside and who's going to do what
has run there definitely go for drink
yes so maybe of a hangover you down you
know I can't rely on beer in most ways
to be able for tolerance as machine is
going down so quite a lot of engineering
issues
what is your terrible so we come on your
accusation and it is what may be like
for all the same policing here volume
velocity writing dealer issues these are
things we have the philosophy of
publishing I decided I have too much
data coming here wanted we need the
speed at which data is communal and then
you have to break this filter it to make
sure like anyway that I don't have a but
even doing back to station just too much
or rather in the tunnels and there is
some we're interesting example to what's
happening in industry Twitter you know
there is some statistics about 3,000
images per second being shared so let
you think about it that's a lot of
selfies
a lot of selfies enter but what's
happening over coming up is what cost
for millions of others for sailors
contribute a message of the day so again
that's with call of challenges from the
infrastructure follow you they don't got
any time when apply let's add a top you
you know you mean a great brave and
that's one guy that's a and I can't
handle it anymore
there are challenges from the produce
upon your in producing information you
dance it's right to consume it or it's
too much of it you know suddenly we know
another thing is trying to replicate the
mixes west of the look for consumers I
can handle the velocity information and
the final thing is variety blue edges
SEO specialist a survivor guy we all
love it
you like it well I wouldn't and the
biggest part of employers like them but
you know excess when she says something
great about it there's a really simple
model to think of whether columns and
rows easy to access the data chip data
to think about no debate happens as
related to what relational databases
remind us of things that might be equal
process well they got a shape of the
data and come to the table with columns
and rows of various figures
but not all data citing a
two-dimensional table the VP who will
sway global company and we deposited in
UK well everyone was exactly so think
about how you model a payroll system
some excitement for a global company in
UK name was added PA
game with God contractors and Japan will
be something completely different
different attributes different tax codes
so there isn't really a simple way to
unify how you model in payrolls be same
for every country it's like mission
impossible to manage you probably
haven't become really rich but again
that the console gets addicted all the
time you've element you scheme so that
time theta and if schema has to evolve
so it's really hard to use and with a
different kind of data structures their
goal is that in a commercial table I
don't like things like masked by
exploring to detail yes justice or
geographical structure there is some
sort way which is build it that just
bring in at each table not ready I'm
sorry like the next work so I know there
is we read one example is among
elephants so how do we model our
relationship at the grass you know in a
2d table it'd be quite difficult to
reason but I can query that in a simple
point so here we looked at it on the
internet you know what else Big Data
technologies available that has all the
volume velocity and variety content
until there is an inclusive place please
carry graphically where the good news is
that it it's not a bit big later
consultant you're going to make a lot of
money put norms and
which area and what we want to do in
this talk is to really quantify two
kinds of clearance problems so get rid
of an idea worth of products we have so
the first one is flash for setting what
vice was testing willing which is that
we've got some data you know West and we
need to process it and maybe use a
little tool available to something like
calculating a payroll monthly job got
all your data in presented okay well Tom
you've got a lot of mashing hood yes so
like I'm trying to trade my neural
networks detect with a capital does
probably have this one big big bed and
I'm just going to Train it what I wanted
to present training in order to take an
image they all think they're not only
images coming in throughout the training
and I'm trying to date a because of the
images absolutely one egg cream
another double who will serve financial
organization take a bar with that yes
couple hot blooded deal and show you all
of regulation and virtually reports all
right so that's again that sounds like
resetting jobs did you get all the
trades and Islam and then getting some
new data presented the product sexual
told you you know this is kind of a hard
to visualize or even storage of the data
folder they get it / protecting here
takes it setting people
now we consider by the latency of the
patient art science equation so when you
really consent I hate making good use of
resources available to each super is
important but the other side of stories
we prefer that the area that the data is
coming emotion into presented now it
concerned with latency for the operation
for example you know payment system it
will be able to tell whether the in
transactions and firstly process or its
provenance or not that it will
conferences as a miss screen process
indicated that's where an email is tamil
not without its weight is a consistent
another dentistry professional
publication and the effectively hide it
but not only had me some intermediate
data storage you could have them come to
you and some parts of Canada may really
what you want to do is course as a
baseline motion and a lot selected
results okay so what we are doing right
to bespoke is to focus on the batch
processing aspect of public before we do
that let's check how we doing the hidden
liquid investment prices when you guys
so the first ones in advance sheet from
all the invoices internal we think that
the best processing personal Street for
second equation that's awesome
what about the second one real-time
alerts strangely okay great
and so one bit more cheeky what a thing
like third one that it's abused well
thank you listen researchers page one
second yeah so like angry and but it
should be noted that the reason is match
isn't so much because of the
computational the contagious sell their
futures intrinsic Dutch we do have data
that's coming in all the time making our
rats lot of web pages are changing as if
they're any because the rate how which
are which either that information is
coming is so high there's no way we
typically positive ratings remember so
we use outdated and every holiday new
batch communication again and you want a
turn PageRank again but I do it and the
last one through in processing also so
here what we're going to do now is
people just on the budget assessing the
spec so well done hey I've got some big
data for you what you going to do with
it
good question so now we're going to
switch from the forward planner talking
about the challenges so we'll kind of
printing which make sure you know what
you're talking about how we actually how
is how are they different
so they answer my letter and I've got
some typing program innately good learn
which different data matters well now
this that open this is my little chin
here is peace with so how do you I mean
there's got bigger this little power in
one way one thing that I can do is
scalar and this method is used a lot of
times I just like this one machine basil
fingers and there's an alternative to
this which is has all been painted by
Google
and I think I clean up before when she
got retreats unemployment is not the
fishing season others where you can say
you're scaling apps and instead of
buying many big machines is publishing
with hands like a sulphur atoms which
are all connected to get some enjoyment
so let's think of what the trade-offs
are between these two approaches so on
the skating outside something that is
very nice compared to what I used to
have with my laptop is I keep the same
programming model so having a hidden
program of my daughter Sonia have a
machine with a certificate and I can
fish it just go on other than
et2 and get that today I'll still be
able to use one explain how you can
program and it will be a lock on the
there is from downstairs for channel
that is going to cost me a lot of money
it's not very flexible so it's tomorrow
the amount of data done Franco says
doubles there's nothing I can do about
it just cut with the machine which is
the basic second time and also you have
a single for Nvidia this mention breaks
when we make something different on the
other hand I could scale out so I could
many missions that want and if you look
at all the columns that we listed for
clearing up the kind of result by this
day and suddenly it's a lot cheaper to
rent this function it's a lot more
flexible is tomorrow my data the amount
of data I have doubles I can double the
size make cuts and I'm happy and it's
called tolerance is this had a single
point of failure anymore if any of my
machine fails that still have to pull
the other women like the function of the
ones dial eyes which are said to be able
to serve requests but the big downside
of this approach then like it shouldn't
become be exercising of that content
page is the rectory because of this is
that suddenly I use a lot of program
model flexibility my item program that
was really well on my single machine now
doesn't work so what are we going to do
about it so if you look at the images so
we still have school our machine and
what music is this energy and this is
talking about in this book it's kind of
goofy like you just have one huge
machine instead of equipment it
abstracts it in a way which makes it
similar to single machine so you can
pick up some of the things that an
operating system provides to you and try
to think and catalyst to what group does
that also quite equal in function so say
one of the lowest level things I want
matrix operating system to do it if Isis
I want to be able to have some sort of
order structure which is nested and
hierarchical be able to solve item these
in here and complete them and that's
exactly what Ruby she herself was making
that now that Amazon s3 is very popular
and as facility and so immediately from
system say something that's important to
note is that they all have to take
properties which are the ones who want
from the very slide one table so if
again if I double the amount of breaking
attribute and it also double the size of
my cluster things kind of take the you
tomorrow
and second-floor problem it's penny as a
machine in my justified list when you
make to your 3d machine dying my cluster
I'm still able to pull from just as well
as I and this is because to have so many
issues it's very likely government okay
so our PI system innovation
now remote management is another thing
we may go subscribe and this one is the
stillness of you let me see your pretty
good and what it does is basically tells
you it looks at all of them she's have
and it looks at all the all you have the
amount of memory you have energy just
the sort of framework responsible for
saying you get totals and yet the six
machines which each article with 200 ma
try to contribute and give a total for
keeping track of which programming
things which goals in which men and at
the end when a program finished
terminates only gives this because in
this memory microwave so that yumpin
give it to some other person so finally
and this is kind of equivalent of our
Python program and it doesn't have some
data purchasing programs we have to do
poverty and if s there is try to offer
the same scoops of obstruction it turns
out that such as Pakistan before recent
one has a low the first it's because
emitted shaming in sauce and pasta and
also in high school high school and so
that's what we're going to talk about in
the rest of the folks are super duper
surrounding and the product is actually
advanced for
Yaron for Dark Ages so I do business I
think in the well this is I think this
book
I think initiative is just kind of like
five systems and the new MapReduce for
the project
now will people all the Hadoop against
SMU develop all the frameworks which
were necessarily under the hood but also
like invitation so perhaps part even no
links with the difference in itself
which in practice but of people clubs
very yes I know that you can what a
person spot with other resource packages
yeah that's yep can you also use other
file systems yes you're going to use a
free where she going to use the three
notes you know do anything okay all
right all the time work with could you
be consistent and also operating pieces
that's right I think the thing is system
like now really you should see as a set
of open source frameworks which they you
know they just like skating out later
precinct and that's all I kind of fit
together but they did for like there's
many sort of make pieces of the puzzle
that obligated intellect is multiple
frameworks at copán
for example which uses spark sunlight
lots of work and I don't
I can spot so we're going to do now is
do a bit of like cooing get a feel for
the spoke API or consultations were able
to to do and we need fancy tool equals
exactly and I think really local and
what Devon is essentially I feel like a
title of a book so a bit of a rebel
no you're you type some code in here
what pursuer sugar one sign out and
gives you the result okay but a benefit
to provide on top of quite the mood
which is that there is integrated
support for different data invasion but
can the pie chart or graph based on the
data and will use some of those tools
okay so what we're going to do it is to
use a dataset from the open library this
is data the old can plug that were
published it's a big Jason fight and
here's a sample of them it looks nice on
you
okay there's kind of a real world is
that I can build yourself this is just a
little sample here you know it's not
very big but the real one is about how
to keep my data okay so the first thing
we you may wish to do is to first look
at stuff so this is how to improve on
long hair is the one we call it in the
world account so gzip I'm saying look it
up and you know what enables to find out
is to me you know how many elements
there are in this fire right so sexy
where does it so many lines there is in
that unified so what is that what's
realizes I would completely decoupled
from the threading model or the
processing
I'm a pianist it's a cup of it it's
running locally on my machine but to
take that same code and run it over a
cluster of machines so I can get a nice
decoupling between the operations and
their communication so here's another
right well let's of the celestine came
on Tyler what's what is she going with
it so the first entry you can take the
string and that's a line in that slide
okay so the beautiful book called the
epic will depreciate and machi
yeah sure we're going to read the book
but exponentially so we're gonna touch a
string and require to be able to break
out of this object as pison objects what
completely title that would you so I'm
allergic to the texture so it's
converted talking to on an object so
there's a nice module called attainment
just to get bigger scale or how this
works toilet table cutter contains a
table which might be something like that
so aim and that would be e that's right
up perfect to end so sorry there we go
perfect and now what we wish to do is to
be able to say how do you convert that
into a piping structure okay so now I'm
gonna fight an object which means I can
say something like that or title and I
can extract
yeah pathologic so what we want to do is
convert each line in spire into Python
object so we get confident using - which
ultimately is what we want so there is a
pressure call map available in spark
what I'm going to do is to apply
function on each element coming from
that initially so first let's figure out
what worked through data a kind of a
special type head a certain spark so an
RDD the converse or the defense or
sometimes it's a resilient the truth
detective very hunky name but it really
isn't necessary for example is some data
set back with me to the multiple
machines million to the one machine and
has many distinct elements which make
you a victim thank you very lucky that I
can list whether more time see and you
know the whole thing can be distributed
so such thing we want to do is to
convert each of those life into personal
capsule and not this and Python is
sponsoring it in the notes so that's
going to be a new ology legal okay so if
I the oddity but can't here but we'll
see design actually we have the same
environment as before right so nothing
change hey but if we say you know take
the first 10 okay what you'll see that
now where she get a list of Python
object and those three things that the
nice window will get okay now well I'd
like to know we both live in Cambridge
on to find out about books that have
Cambridge in it
okay so if I have an ally from
operations I can call them an RDD
and again sit behind a dresser this will
be completely discrete as a filter I can
do filter and what I'm going to pass
here is function so things that won't
get a book service blue Cambridge's has
so let's say we're going to pass that a
lambda function which is a return true
there is Cambridge in the title and
possibly under safety symmetry and then
we further me check that title is in our
in the entry living service and that
Cambridge
and alter in it in the title I'm gonna
do the countersign how many you know
everything actual what it was get a
little sample in the first place so all
you do is think
okay sorry
a new team a new king spirit in school
can select one of these actually become
athletes were a bit messy all I really
want is just the type of injustice on
your title so yeah so we visit
celebration and what this really return
is another of so we can still apply it
same kind of operation function and now
MIT need a clear map and we have all
these 17 countries and each of them are
going to give their quizzes in the
bishop and we're going to pass a
function against a lambda which takes a
bit and just returns the title of us we
know that the book has a title of this
or which helps out what wish did amazing
so the reason cell phones first quite
forgettable them if I collect any
enhancer go crazy okay there's a new
Cambridge English menu Cambridge English
will you keep it english see you that
this is this one may be their first time
but
clinical governments really of kinships
that were metals and partnership
initiative Sonia alright so that's where
we can compose the pressures together
that's fantastic but you just mentioned
it titleholder the key available this
base has the pelvic floor whatever
attributes available in a dataset okay
so maybe the powerless as we still have
our G and let's have a look at how many
of each of them has a different world
has a number of entry and exit key value
store and maybe they have a look at for
each how many of them have seven dollars
how are you happy to lose cute George
okay just one of the ski little red x's
so all that we need to do in our keys so
we call it plasma another equation like
Martin doesn't wear will return for each
box is going to be the keys another and
the reason we use flat my page because
key return a list of things like some
got math you end up having a unless a
release of a little stuff it's not
really useful so gets flattened all
those internal list in the pack so
exactly so with the [ __ ] lapping at
the very bottom there i'm each for each
good i'm going to get many entries
corresponding to all of the keys at this
before we had something like that one
hundred thousand bucks so maybe now our
RT is going to have like Commission and
and then what I'm calling is this thing
so now the think is going to remove all
of the document you and then I pulled up
a couple can take your campus
okay because I'll 7010 I will collect
animals inserting those wishes we should
worship and pipe this is a very
misstatement and like some keys are
duplicated in name when we have the
publisher death date of yours laughs
never fade problem initially if us taste
all right
I have interesting on without the
worldly distributions limited Maggie
mosquito they said maybe not all total
death date there are given distribution
or wanted okay so the first thing I want
to do is to see how many to map people
from having from just a store value to
something that tells us about the
numbers if they have so
length of yoki and then the second thing
you can cool
and then under GTA is actually returns
select next Keith and then one and this
one is gonna make sense in a second as I
to the second operation that's it's
useful that we've got very little time
the keys for the little cheeseburger for
specific book and then the occurred for
what
so then the operation I'm going to call
and it's worth noting that what I'm
doing here is actually exactly will not
reduce it so the gravity's it kind of
like conversation pattern and the
conversation has an amazing here is
exactly America and the Republic of
course we G slices and then a has a
function which takes two images will two
numbers x and y any times X plus one and
so what I'm doing it in the first set
and lifting as key the number of entries
after that the record time so we had
just title and ethics depreciation and
so that was a two and if another one has
horses 21 and four months now that's two
up to one it is going to become a ski
and I'm going to add up all of the key
for of the one that associated with that
pieces if I have a 2-1 somewhere a 2-1
elsewhere and a final two one at the
very bottom and then I get three of them
and one under name is Douglas as
everything psyche is a 2 and then a 3
that all these three ones are going to
happen done so maybe let's the record
open a third collection
they sold it to Bibles in Cairo I be
tripping and joke to them
I'm gonna complicate it
also let's print out
look at this like the 6096
and she went 1411 plan which happened a
little tunnel I am Lori a text guy I
like three pretty graphs and visuals
just so I can understand prepare by the
data so have you got something about
mantra staying may be integrated exactly
but that's a really good question
so um now listen actually has a really
neat way to like a very easy way to
print data so what I'm telling here is
I'm putting this in okay so about to
give you table and then they just passed
on with a purpose for each entry in
and then what I'm going to prepare is
this item click type so percentage D
this is a decimal I'm going to have to
them with a backslash T in the middle
and this is something seldom to
percentage fee that the two decimals I
need to get and those are going to be
ef-0 and ef-1 so normally might be using
kind of my partner to do all the work
for you but here we will disclose okay
so we have a table it's not that much
better than having it printed it before
so now we can do you have different
print out the histogram because you
wouldn't never keep their samokov
expanded if you have a mode if you have
nothing quite quickly let you interact
and critic my favorite part is right
because it's what you want to do it it
is a little the little done which is all
this processing locally so you know a
sample of big data set the fields right
let's take this to the next level let's
go we were g'bye this data homebuilders
okay so hey again this was just an
awesome and this is because we had a
small subset on the later but if you
actually look at the entirety relations
with the play disease that I had to
learn every container it's actually so
f3 is this service provided by Amazon
where you can uploaded a step and it's
kind of like ETFs which are essential
all the states will be replicated in
major places and you really to test it
and see can be nice to do 500 things
with the book and okay so now now that
we have this data prove it all right how
do we play with this in a scalable way
how can we grab many how can we grab
many we haven't
okay so first maybe just a little
spoiler the surprise where she has a
little notebook head running on top of
simple anymore
that was gonna shall gonna say same code
as before
all right we put inside lyric from a
local local fire Louie from history
I'm just gonna write a code and you said
starting and we'll come back to it in
seconds not I was ear bomb so get up
under the knee a mouthful Amazon Elastic
MapReduce and it's the new service or
rather reasons that it provided by
Amazon and the idea is that before we
had out of any to you which morning
machines
EML also sets up your machine so they
have all of the frameworks that you
wanted to support you can have spoken to
on producing tenacity and you can see
here there's example examples of many
more HS or they expressed applies
community so they're example
I can see you have a list of services
and a recently visited one is give up so
you can see so here we have a set of
clusters we've already loaded but maybe
let's have a look at what would happen
if you wanted criticism so many choices
so if you we've actually affected maybe
like to apply and municipal public
speeches business with when othering
decide but let's have a look at what
happens if we didn't want to create a
cluster right now so as you may imagine
I didn't call the joys of like say to
you sensitive the name which is simple
launch mode and then I think what your
point is that as you can set which which
frameworks you want so here is giving
you the couples of spendable
configurations where and the top one has
to do a high taste test
the one we take our sorry like all the
structures from the hdfs your I think
that's right get up
yeah it's also I think is presentation
yet efficient as young and lovely
because it's like dinner in the Cabana
so the one we think was divided into
four toys uh no sorry sir
local the wooded to do is going to
support many instances in the subject in
the Amazon basin and all of them will
habitus so today we have to had a couple
of different experience I think I really
want to and I should collect in vacuum
accommodating a compressor so terraces
stack your set up and then below we can
configure welcome instance I'd we'd like
to have so particular missionary work
Cindy where I'm from one ball and four
calls and the number of the influences
that you also have in that cell cluster
sober example when we actually found it
here we 460 machine the disease has been
to one master machine the one
coordinating a thing and if you go back
and you can set up the pro mention the
instant pipes if we wanted to be crazy
you instead of pick the largest of the
key one this one which I think
we didn't get that one okay so now let's
have a look at what happens as we catch
this was created before so for we people
oh let's have a look now something
that's ringing is that if you just down
the page you can see here we have a list
of connections and these are links that
we can click to just directly have a
look so you know that I think I've
already had it done before the way they
opened it was very simple we just picked
it and it isn't signed up and over which
is on top of my digital self information
that she was she's willing you know we
can uh she checked this while I'm going
to use to and will be the blood will
still have got nineteen and twenty two
exams the all the machine that was kind
of right because you check us and only
all these each other
alright so the public app remember we
did a query will be counted and above
lines and that makes it to be white
house so I was still working and
something that we should be able to see
now is in the list of Gambia which is
really it tells you it's off like
monitoring components or older version
here process so click on Kenya you can
see them as we asked account from the
bollocks like us is our Swedish round
straight up
and down the load okay this ever tells
you are you machine saturated or you
which means open the memory hasn't
changed much and the reason is actually
think this in the make against you think
that storm we favor the late side enemy
Plan C you know he takes about a you
know six minutes you to what
begin to whether you get with a funky
music EMR that decouple ourselves from
the execution model since Eclipse roads
they were working with locally run it
over cluster that's a great way from the
configuration point of view sparks or
you can pipe events calendar masters the
technologies that you use at work and
there's a quite simple conceptual and
migrations who collects box for yes
so my custom image a like one with
exactly the high school I may be misled
I thought I actually set up the base am
I did you know what may arise so like
it's an EMI source or an image that you
come for another national image of MA so
important things in a virtual machine on
an instance and I'm so excited that I
can search the exact version of an
estrangement so as you could set up a
face a my perfect amenable to that
there's also ways to can cut on this
sort of of your clusters of approach
that most of the risk
great to fish so this is the answer of
this could be the greatest hammock I
have attacked next to keep my pack and
it will just work on the talk some talk
about you are and you know what thing to
really consider it we would just use the
gigantic Cajun spice David Kellum
identify for my lady is a lot of
practice and are you still there what if
um Jim polishes process very fundamental
it's really very practice you'll often
get a win by burning your beers and we
may talk cash let's talk about parquet
this morning which is part of my medical
format which is totally encoding and
compressed as well we use reduce the
side of the time which means less
transfer between the little machines to
get away from that front and with any
query over me run more efficiently using
something like cotton but the Konami's
keeping contribution it is also quite
cool new tech our prepare disease
approximate clearing system and what do
you guys do which is pretty made him if
they hate now his petabytes of
information and can quarry that we were
second to nobody do it by just telling a
sample behaviour index in acquiring a
sample together an error rate where that
might be perfectly reasonable for
satsang business quite
you know often you know recovery really
exact result it just kind of education
towards it that's starting to mechanical
so a quick run to carry smart would
provide professional development
training for clear-sighted inspiring to
decide to attend another provider
concourses publicly tickets hang up come
over weekend also count on things like
machine learning big data analytics NLP
whether sticks or program early in
London where they DP helping transitions
and commentary slightly less quality
recording of commitment slightly be
greatly to third you guys in cables
running the Cambridge data science
director Cornish in this time Institute
which is a research center for context
and one habit I bet even speak in the
bush
thanks for coming to talk and there is a
bit of running
[Applause]
[Music]